what is like the most popular path to
starting to build an audience and being
able to put yourself in a position to
potentially be able to monetize it like
this
I think the first thing that's important
is to choose
all right guys bang bang I've got Nathan
here Nathan I figure the great place to
start would be the idea of billion
dollar creators there are a bunch of
people we know on the internet they are
working their asses off trying to build
big companies or many different
companies and they're using the
distribution as a competitive Advantage
who do you think has the potential to
become one of these billion dollar
creators okay there's two people that
come to mind right away and we can talk
about people who've already done it
because it's not that crazy of an idea
but two people that I'm watching right
now are Nick Huber and sahil Bloom I
think both of them are gonna pull it off
in a big way Nick because
in the real estate space I think
everyone knows him as sweaty startup on
Twitter and he's got a couple hundred
thousand followers and and all that
but what he's done that's really
interesting is looked at the real estate
transaction which is really expensive
like you think about what it takes to
buy real estate there
like all that and he's breaking it down
and starting businesses around each part
of that transaction and so he shared
these numbers publicly so we'll talk
about it but uh one thing is
you know instead of promoting
um like a digital product right that he
could that's very normal as a Creator
it's a great way to make money but he
actually looked and said like okay what
services can I provide
and he started a uh a real estate cost
segregation business I think it's doing
like 200 000 to 250 000 a month in
Revenue right now and they're like nine
months in
and so he's in this space of like what's
the what's the best way that I can
direct this audience towards
service but something that will make me
money
um I need to spun that up and blown away
it's just doing really really well and
so I think that he's a good example the
other person saw her bloom
he's got like a lot more mainstream with
his content
uh and he's you know building the
newsletter we talked about how he's how
he's growing that really fast but um
he's got this private Equity background
and I'm pretty sure that he's going to
go like acquire a business or focus on
something that then he can use this
distribution to blow up in a big way so
if I were placing bets on like
two people three years from now uh it'd
be those two when you think about buying
versus building do you think most of the
creators are going to end up picking one
or the other or do you think it really
is just a match with their backgrounds
I think that
that's a good question
most people lean toward the building I
think because they see an option an
opportunity there unless you have a
background like sahil does and in
investing in private equity
um I think most people think about about
building from scratch
and that's kind of the Creator way right
of like I built an audience from scratch
you know maybe I built this other
business from scratch so let me keep
doing that
but buying is really interesting because
you can accelerate the process
um I've bought two companies now and
like
it's so much faster it can be a total
pain what are the two companies that you
bought
uh one of them is a company called
fanbridge which is email marketing for
musicians uh we were getting into that
um
uh that space a little while ago it's a
company that had raised a lot of venture
capital and then had kind of stalled out
I think actually we're going to see a
lot of companies right now
um
in this like down Venture Market I think
there's going to be a lot of companies
that can't raise the next round that are
uh really good targets to buy
um so that one brought over can you talk
about the Dynamics of that deal like are
any of the numbers public in terms of
you know what did they raise what were
they doing why did you guys think that
you could grow it how's it turned out
yeah um the exact terms of the deal are
probably the one thing that I can't
share because it's under NDA
um but the basically they had like 1200
to 1500 customers that were all in the
music space and so in acquiring them you
know we brought over like Leon Bridges
and a whole bunch of other musicians
that were great name brands for us
um and that like in one move uh expanded
that
uh it worked out really well for us
because it's a profitable acquisition
almost from day one you know you get a
company that's that's just like coasting
downhill
um another set of people that are doing
really well is uh these two guys Xavier
and sieva from enduring Adventures yeah
explain a little bit of what they're
doing
I don't know that I can do a great job
they raise the fund uh I think three
years ago and since then they've been
acquiring companies uh they're up to 19
companies they've bought in the last
three years
and they're buying these for cash flow a
few of these that they bought are
um
it's just fantastic like cash flow
businesses two of them at least were
like venture-funded companies that
couldn't raise another round and so they
just bought the assets and and turned it
around and scaled it
um but they're using audience in a lot
of these uh same way that the Nick is
it's just interesting watching what's
going on in the space of people who are
great at acquiring companies I'm not
great at it yet I'm like just trying to
learn from from other people
um but yeah that's it's fun to watch
when you see uh people building audience
first and then either buying or building
the companies on the back end do you
think this is how businesses are going
to be built in the future like you know
it used to be you built the product and
you go and you find the customers now
we're not only seeing uh this happen
with what I'll call like uh the internet
celebrity right people who are big on
Twitter or have a big email list but
we're also seeing you know Kim
Kardashian Kylie Jenner The Rock uh
Conor McGregor like you just go down the
line
um of the like mainstream celebrity but
you're also singing what I'll call like
the crossover Stars so even like a Logan
Paul and KSI with prime they were able
to build an audience on the internet
then they kind of cross over into the
mainstream with WWE or whatever they're
doing they launch the drink they're
doing you know estimates are somewhere
around 250 million dollars a year in
Revenue uh last year and it's just these
massive businesses is this now because
it's possible uh and kind of the cat's
out of the bag that everyone is going to
want the audience first and then the
company or will people still try to
build companies and you know the
quote-unquote traditional way
I I don't know who the quotes from so
we'll have to look it up but
um it's something like first-time
Founders care about product second time
Founders care about distribution
and I think what that's exactly what
you're seeing here of
early on people are like hey I've got
this idea I want to bring it to Market
you know and you're getting to that
first thousand a month in revenue and 10
000 a month and building that up
and that really matters but then
like a lot of times when people are
doing their second third fourth company
they're looking for not what's the best
deal or what's the best company that I
could start or what's the best deal I
could acquire based on the numbers
they're looking at how can I get the
most distribution
and so if you take someone like Nick
Huber right he's all in on distribution
he's got hundreds of thousands of people
paying attention to him on Twitter in
the real estate and small business space
and so he's like great now that I have
this distribution what services and
companies can I pair with that uh and
that's how he's able to launch and scale
these companies really quickly
same thing with
um
you know take someone from years ago
like Mark Sisson with uh Primal kitchen
he had this blog called Mark's Daily
Apple he's in the uh like the paleo
recipe and and uh lifestyle space
and he's got distribution and he can
focus that on
you know selling digital products
courses uh affiliate stuff that's a
great business you can make a couple
million dollars a year as a Creator in
that way no way to make a billion
dollars with that
that more traditional creative path
but what he did is like with this
distribution I want to point it towards
something that I own and so he starts
Primal kitchen it's a uh I think it
starts with a paleo friendly mayonnaise
and they go to ketchups and other sauces
hints of exiting in two years for 200
million dollars to craft
right and because he's able to use his
distribution to Kickstart uh all of this
so yeah you're gonna see a ton more of
that is there going to be this world and
maybe Nick is trying to do this but uh
other folks might be following as well
where people say I want to build this
company but before I get started let me
build out distribution specifically for
this company so it's not hey I already
built an audience now let me go find the
companies and it's kind of the
serendipitous thing but actually people
will say no there's a Playbook on how to
get the distribution so let me actually
go build a new Twitter account let me go
build a specific email list let me build
a podcast specific for this business
right and it's more of like master plan
versus the Serendipity that we've
probably seen with the internet uh
Creator or celebrity today
I'm trying to think of the master plan
side
I don't know that there's as much of
people calling the shot in advance
they're probably doing it privately
behind the scenes
um
but maybe it would come across like as
inauthentic building audience or
something
another example that comes to mind of
someone doing it at the same time and
doing it very deliberately
um is a woman named Susie who started uh
a website called Hey Grill hey
she is like in the barbecue space and so
she decided she built up like one of the
largest uh like barbecue uh brands for
you know a Content site and all of that
but I don't know I think something like
two to three million page views a month
so it's really good sized and then she
had this plan from the early days of
like getting into uh retail and
basically having your own line of
um like barbecue sauces and rubs and all
that and that's something where now
she's just at the point where her
physical products are starting to
eclipse the digital and she's fully in
you know manufacturing getting into
retail stores and all that because I
think she's a good example of like being
deliberate from the beginning and
building both simultaneously
and so she ends up like she's starting a
a
you know a food brand with
like which is something that's very
expensive to do with no outside Capital
because she's got this core content
business that's throwing off you know
three to five million dollars a year in
revenue and so she's able to then scale
up her next thing that's significantly
larger without having to raise capital
for it because she's got basically this
Golden Goose in both distribution and
cash flow from the core business when
you think about these companies
um everything that we're talking about
here is like Creator buys Creator builds
are there going to be large companies or
do we have any examples where a large
business says hey you know what I think
that uh this whole distribution first
model makes sense let me go white label
my product or let me go and partner and
you know I'll use an example if I was
John Deere tractor right do I go find
someone in the in the uh space that's uh
got a huge following of people who are
potential customers for me and I say
look I don't want to do a traditional
influencer do I pay you some money
instead I want to create a branded
tractor for you or I want to create some
sort of subsidiary where you and us are
Partners have we seen any of that type
of stuff happen yet
I haven't seen that specifically I do
know from like the homestead world or uh
I don't know we my most random
investment is a ghost town in California
that we could talk about the whole
content play around that but um
that went like Kubota is this company
you know they're a competitive John
Deere and they're giving out like
tractors and all that and being like
here just uh make sure these make it
into your YouTube videos you know and
that sort of thing and you're like sweet
yeah thank you for the 30 000 tractor
I'll I'll make sure you use it in videos
so there's a lot of the influencer play
but I haven't seen someone like partner
in a white label sense maybe it's
happening behind the scenes and I'm just
not seeing it I think this is like one
of the biggest opportunities in the
world right now is if you're a large
company especially if you're like a
multinational or multi-billion dollar
company the extra cost and kind of the
risk You Take by simply partnering with
someone and saying hey look let us
deliver the same exact product but we
want to do some sort of co-branded deal
maybe the best thing that we've seen is
like the lvmhs of the world or somebody
like that we've kind of seen we've also
seen a lot of like uh champagne
companies or alcohol businesses that
they're like closely intertwined but you
can imagine if
um you know again maybe John Deere and a
NASCAR driver teamed up and there was
like a Dale Earnhardt you know uh John
Deere tractor right I'm completely
making this up but like totally it's
selling right like like it's selling to
someone somewhere uh and so it gets in
this weird world of like okay that's
like a super super Niche product with a
super Niche uh type of person for uh
kind of an overlapped audience but if
you then back up and you say hold on a
second well what about food products
what about uh software products what
about all these other things
um it feels kind of dumb for people not
to try to go do this and so I do wonder
how much of it is just they haven't
gotten there yet they don't understand
uh the value versus actually uh the
creators are saying why would I partner
with you I can just buy it myself or I
can build it myself I don't need you
I've got the thing that is unique which
is the audience the product itself is
you know somewhat commoditized at this
point
yeah I agree though I think that
creators could could make a mistake of
productizing or commoditizing the
product too much because if you think of
it as okay I have the distribution
that's 90 of the work and then the
product is 10 you know and maybe
someone's like going on Alibaba and
figuring out like oh I'm gonna white
label these water bottles and you know
sell them at a 20x markup or something
like that if you don't have that passion
for the product as well then I think at
some point you're going to lose interest
and move on from the
um
like that that whole idea and so I would
really encourage creators to think about
what's the thing that I want to be all
in on this product through these
distribution channels for a long time
because if you're just like hey 99
distribution 10 attack on a product I
think that's gonna ultimately fail or
you might make a bunch of value and then
be able to sell it off but it's not like
I'm gonna have to do this for years to
get to a billion dollar brand and so
it's really like what's the product that
I'm really passionate about that I can
use this unfair advantage and
distribution that I have to Kickstart it
and get it to this next level
right like using the Primal kitchen
example Mark Sisson can do things like
you say he gets his first Whole Foods
deal or some grocery store right and
they're in like two stores and it's a
little test to see how it goes well he
can go on his email list and be like
okay everybody within 50 miles of the
store in Austin like email just them be
like hey go buy our new products in
Whole Foods right and so Whole Foods is
going to be like whoa this sold out this
is amazing you know let's let's ramp it
up let's let's try it out in more stores
so because he has this digital advantage
but I think it it really needs to be
that the audience is kickstarting
a meaningful brand
um that then you're gonna scale through
traditional channels and and all that
rather than just being
um that I since I have this distribution
let me see what I can tackle on
you and I have talked in the past about
these idea of partner networks as well
basically other types of Revenue uh that
somebody can get so they can obviously
sell a product or a service directly to
Their audience uh but now there are
these products that are popping up where
basically creators can get paid for
making referrals to other products or
other creators talk a little bit about
how those are working I think you've
even invested in one maybe
um and kind of like what why is that so
interesting to you
yeah so this one is a company called
spark Loop that we invested in a couple
years ago for their they had a referral
product where you like if you're running
a newsletter and you want to do like a
morning Brew style uh referral right of
you know refer three friends and I'll
give you the sticker this hat
um this digital download any of that so
they had that product now what they're
doing that I think is really interesting
is they built out a
a network where you can advertise and
say hey I'll pay as a Creator I'll pay
two dollars per subscriber that anyone
refers to me
and so you have all these creators who
have been spending on you know Facebook
and Google and and those especially with
Apple's privacy changes right those ad
rates that tended to to get quite a bit
more expensive
and so now what they're doing is saying
hey I'll pay other creators and so think
of it like
um the like sub Stacks recommendations
right
it's that but paid and so you get the
two sides of it so using sahil Bloom as
an example he's spending 25 000 a month
on this network at the moment where he's
saying to other creators like
refer quality subscribers to me I'm only
going to pay for the people who are
engaged I'll pay you know a dollar fifty
two dollars a subscriber and then other
people are able to say like great this
is a great new Revenue stream for me
when someone signs up for my newsletter
it pops up and says hey do you also want
to subscribe to sahil bloom and Nick
Huber and you know maybe a couple other
people and I'm getting paid for that on
the front end and so what's wild about
that is
you and I have run lots of paid ads over
the years and you always think in terms
of payback period right how long if I
run an ad how long does it take for me
to make back the money that I spent
um maybe if we're doing e-commerce or
something I'm trying to have like a
30-day payback period in in software or
SAS if you've raised Capital unit you're
like oh if I get a 12 month payback
period like that's fantastic
but in this case you could you know as a
Creator you're getting paid on the front
end as new people are joining your list
and so it's great on both sides of that
Marketplace both of
um joining the list and then also like
both for the Creator who's referring and
saying hey I'm getting paid right away
and then the Creator who's basically in
that sponsor role and saying um
uh like I'm paying other creators for
engaged subscribers rather than going
from Instagram through a funnel and all
the way down I think the other part of
it that's really interesting using sawho
is an example again
he's actually he sells sponsorships on
his newsletter
and so like that's a steady Revenue
stream and he's taking a hundred percent
of what he makes in the the sponsorships
and turning around and spending it to
grow faster and so he's adding something
like 50 to 80 000 subscribers a month
um through all you know when he's doing
on social and all this because he's just
got this flywheel that's running super
super fast and so when you start to see
these partner networks do you think that
it'll only be for email subscribers or
do you think that they will eventually
be hey I want more Instagram followers I
want more podcast downloads I want more
uh you know people at my conference or
whatever other things uh some of these
folks are doing like will it spread into
other mediums or do you think email is
uniquely positioned to work here
it's a good question I think the reason
it's going to work well in email is that
email subscribers are worth a lot
and and people tend to know okay if I
set up these automations to promote you
know this product then I can pay two
dollars a subscriber four dollars a
subscriber all day and have a good
payback period
and then also
a lot of the infrastructure exists on
this now but the the idea of a partner
Network like this I think is super new I
haven't seen
I haven't seen a play out in uh
in these other channels yeah but I mean
it would totally work in podcasts well I
even like the idea in like conference
registrations you know I'm running an
event and uh
like it's totally worth it if you're
like hey I'll I'll pay for referrals and
all that so it's kind of like everything
old is new again you know there's
nothing like this recommendations thing
it's just code registration like that's
been around in online marketing forever
but now it's being brought to the
Creator space
um partner networks it's just this
affiliate idea but brought specifically
to to content in a new way and so I
think we're seeing these things get
reinvented and it'll be interesting to
see which ones
uh which ones stick and which ones end
up like kind of dropping off talk a
little bit about marketing flywheels in
general like obviously a partner Network
you're paying dollars right you're
trying to get some sort of uh kind of
top of funnel growth that funnel that
top of funnel growth hopefully will lead
to a flywheel but you all have spent a
lot of time thinking about this what
have you seen work there and whatnot
yeah so just for anyone in your audience
who might not know what a flywheel is if
you imagine like a water pump uh I don't
know when I was a kid we'd go camping
somewhere you know and you'd have to
like it's this pump where you're going
up and down with the handle
um and there's a constant amount of
effort that goes into
creating a pretty constant output you
know each each pump of a handle produces
a certain amount of water
now a flywheel is a different way of
doing it where you end up with this big
metal wheel sitting on top of the
um of the pump and it might be super
hard to get going like when you first
turn that it's it's um
really challenging you know
but then over time as it gets the
momentum going it gets easier and easier
and then at that point you could be
pumping water out as well just like
standing there with one hand just like
casually spinning it
um
and so kind of the rules of a flywheel
are that instead of it being like
one-off activities you've made it so
that each thing flows smoothly into the
next it's a continuous motion
the next thing is that um
each turn of the flywheel should be a
tiny bit easier than the last and each
turn of the flywheel should produce a
little bit more output than the last one
so that's a real world example of
something then we want to bring it to
the digital space
so talking about like sahib Bloom for
example
he's got I don't know what 800 000
followers on Twitter now he's he's built
a great audience
and he's built a flywheel around his
email newsletter and so he's pushing
from uh Twitter Instagram Etc into email
he's got it where uh when someone joins
his list they're getting welcome emails
that's like automated
um
and then he you know if he wanted he
could sell digital products there and
that would earn more per subscriber
then he's selling newsletter or he's
selling sponsorships in his newsletter
and so he's at this point making 25 to
30 000 a month
selling
um sponsorships and the more subscribers
he has the more money he earns
but what he cares about the most is
growing the newsletter as fast as
possible right he's trying to say hey
can I go from 200 000 subscribers at the
beginning of the year to a million at
the end of the year uh for a book launch
and so then what's happening is
he's got a referral program in place
where he's saying hey if you refer
people to me then I'm going to give you
an incentive so that takes like every
one subscriber who enters the top of the
funnel and turns it into say 1.2 like
it's a little bit of a lift there
and then the revenue that he's
generating is he's pouring All the Way
Forward into this partner Network
to pay people you know to grow his list
faster
so basically the
the bigger his list is the more he can
charge advertisers the more money he
makes which means the more money he can
spend to grow those faster which is the
makes his list bigger which means he can
spend more on Advertising which means
he's making more money
so early on this flywheel say was
producing 10 to 15 000 a month in cash
flow all which was getting reinvested
now as it's bigger each rotation it's
producing thirty thousand dollars a
month in cash flow and he's reinvesting
that which means it gets bigger and so
you're watching these results compound
more and more and instead of doing a
bunch of one-off activities to grow his
audience
he's putting it all into this automated
system and flywheel and saying okay how
can I tweak this how can I improve the
onboarding emails how can I sell
sponsors for a little bit more
um and then it is just watching it get
faster and faster and it's gonna come
out in a big way and yeah like I fully
expect him to hit a million subscribers
by like within the next year
and so once somebody has a million email
subscribers whether it's him or somebody
else what do you think is the best way
to monetize it keep selling the ads is
it launch a product uh is it try to sell
digital products uh or do you actually
think it's like do everything
well are we going for cash flow or
Enterprise Value so that that is the
ultimate question right is what I see a
lot of folks doing is actually
optimizing for the cash flow not
necessarily optimizing for the
Enterprise Value and it brings up uh one
of the like trillion dollar questions of
this whole thing which is if people put
their name on it are they able to sell
it or are they willing to sell it right
there is uh there's somebody who I don't
want to uh bring up because I don't know
how comfortable he is uh with it being
talked about publicly but his name was
on uh a very big email list he sold it
and a couple years ago the company who
bought it they're blasting his name and
image all over the place in ways that
maybe he wasn't you know so excited
about but it was look his name and image
were part of the deal and so you know he
I haven't asked them specifically but
I'm sure he probably regrets that
component of it at a minimum and so same
thing with you know Rogan's podcast he
can't sell it because he can't walk away
so he can license it he can do all these
things but like The Joe Rogan you know
uh experience is Joe Rogan and so you
know same thing with a number of people
that we've seen build some of this stuff
it feels like maybe why they're building
their products or the companies uh is
because that has Enterprise Value even
if uh maybe the content doesn't
yeah so I don't think you have to choose
like it's it's not a totally binary of
cash flow versus Enterprise Value
because you can do both you could have
the advertising or you know some digital
products or something else that does
good cash flow and then one of these
businesses that you're
spinning up buying incubating that's
really going to build up the Enterprise
Value uh it's an example like
because Joe Rogan was involved with on
it right and promoted them in the early
days I think I think he maybe even uh
owned uh Equity there with all a portion
of it yeah yeah so so that kind of thing
of
he can do Joe Rogan can do cash flow
through sponsorships for his podcast and
then he's like oh but I can't
necessarily sell the podcast nor would I
want to
and so let me do
like let me spin up something that like
the next on it or that sort of thing
that then is going to have Enterprise
Value can be invested in can be sold
and is kickstarted with the name and
distribution but is not directly tied to
it
so I think if you take like sahil for
example
the obvious path that's for most
creators is
sell a book you know that's gonna
continue to grow the audience that's
going to drive good Revenue
um
like if you look at James Clear having
the most popular book on Amazon selling
whatever however many million copies a
year like helpful he's doing just fine
no no one feels bad for him
um and that's driving great cash flow
but then also like that's not gonna turn
into something worth a billion dollars
unless you go and deliberately
do it and so I I think it's finding that
balance to make sure you're getting
enough cash flow that you're set you're
not stressed about money you can take
these big swings because I personally
care about Enterprise Value that's what
I'm like I want to lock in Baseline cash
flow and then I'm like look what's gonna
get to something worth 100 million or a
billion dollars or more so let's talk
about somebody who's just starting out
like we're talking about people who
already have things working they're
trying to scale it they're you know they
have 20 30 000 a month to reinvest in
partner network with all this stuff
there's somebody listening to this right
now who's like cool I want to do this
stuff this sounds awesome uh I have
nothing I have no Twitter audience I
have no email I don't even know where to
begin what do I do and so for those
people what have you seen as maybe like
the most uh popular path there's a bunch
of ways to do it but what is like the
most popular path to starting to build
an audience and being able to put
yourself in a position to potentially be
able to monetize it like this
I think the first thing that's important
is to choose like a specific niche
people might see someone
like Joe Rogan who's able to interview
people on every topic and that's part of
what makes the show so interesting is
that
you know it's this broad range of people
they have on and so then you're like oh
I'm gonna start a podcast and I'm gonna
go super super broad or start a
newsletter or Twitter audience and I
think the most important thing that you
can do if you're starting from scratch
is to go really narrow
and say this is exactly who I'm creating
content for
one example for that is when I first
started convertkit I was like hey I'm
building another email marketing company
and it was for like I had here's why
it's better for features and all that
but it didn't actually take off until I
chose a very specific Niche and I said
we're gonna ignore the broad market and
I'm gonna build something just for
professional bloggers and so in actually
um focusing in on that that's when we
got traction
so the for the first thing is choose a
niche even though it means excluding
people it's the easiest advice to give
and the hardest advice to actually take
for yourself
I think the next thing is
taking like a direct Outreach approach
um and really going through and building
out
like
there's the idea of if I write great
content and put it out there like people
will find it
and if you look at a lot of the kind of
Critters that we respect now none of
them had to build it and they will come
or write it and they will come approach
they all very deliberately went out and
um
okay
like evangelize their content in other
places like James Clear when he was
first building his newsletter before he
was well known he was guest posting
non-stop like he was he was writing in
all of these other communities and and
going out to where readers were
putting content there writing something
exactly for that that Community whether
it's Huffington Post or quora or
wherever else
and then bringing them back I think
another great example is um
Jason lemkin who runs disaster it's now
this giant Community you know he gets
like I don't know five eight thousand
people to show up in person for a SAS
conference he's considered like one of
the greatest minds and content creators
in SAS and he has the track record to
back it up but he's built and sold
multiple companies he clearly knows his
stuff but he got started writing on
quora he just would go on quora every
day and answer everybody's SAS questions
someone's like hey what's a good ltp to
cack ratio and he'd be like oh here's
how you should think about it you know
he I don't know what the the numbers are
but I think he answered thousands of
questions on a horror like building that
muscle of writing and then people be
like who's this Jason guy I keep coming
across him oh he has his own newsletter
he has his own blog okay I'll start to
follow that and it wasn't because he was
like spamming Reddit with like here's my
latest post he was just genuinely being
really really useful in communities that
already existed and then we've seen it
play out into
you know hundreds of millions of dollars
of ticket sales to conferences and uh an
investment fund and all kinds of other
great stuff but it really just started
with going to where the audience is and
trying to see how much value he could
provide directly that that makes a ton
of sense and it's basically uh no
different than um you know this idea of
like something super viral on Twitter a
lot of people will start talking about
it right because obviously hearing side
balls you're able to then siphon them
into followers once you get them as
followers you can then bring them to
your email Etc so it makes uh makes a
lot of sense
um you recently had a trip to Cabo and
uh Nick Huber was actually telling me
he's like I should ask you what your
biggest takeaways from the trip were so
what uh man tell us a little bit about
the trip and then what are some of the
takeaways that you had uh that trip was
so good like uh well first Nick is the
only person on that trip that I had
actually met in person before Soho was
on the trip as well and he and I text
all the time but I never met him in
person so that was fun so I think the
first takeaway is
just make the time to meet up in person
um like Matt the guy who organized it
you know happens to have this like
amazing condo at the super fancy
exclusive Resort where like walking by
like oh hi Michael Phelps you know or
like but you don't need that like to
host it you know renting a four or five
bedroom Airbnb somewhere random you know
and having everyone fly in like that's
great just the idea of getting these
smart people together and jamming on
business for a long time
uh was really really important it was
huge one thing
see a couple other takeaways
coming from like the startup space I
think a lot about Revenue growth and
churn and I'll talk about those numbers
I don't talk about ebitda and cash flow
nearly at all and all of these guys
describe their businesses in terms of
how much ebitda it did and that was like
a shift for me where I was like oh
okay I've been in one bubble and it's
just like Revenue growth and like
convert it's profitable that's part of
running a sustainable bootstrap company
um but it's just interesting hearing how
efficiently people can run their
businesses
I think the second thing or I don't know
third thing I don't know where we're at
uh in the uh
in the list of takeaways but
the way people were spinning up
businesses quickly like I'm I'm all in
on one thing
and listening to these guys like
um
uh cieva and Xavier from enduring
Ventures
they're like 19 companies you know and
they're doing all these things and it's
because they're hiring great CEOs for
every company and they're like we won't
buy a company unless we have like we
know who's going to operate it and run
it long term
and I tend to like if I'm spinning up a
new idea inside convert it I'm like oh
I'll run it for a while and they're just
like no no no no like you there's no
scale on that you can't do that you have
to find
um and find the operators you're gonna
make it happen
Nick's doing a great job with that with
his businesses of he'll spin up a new
business and the the thing he talks
about all the time is who am I going to
find to run it like I have this idea
I imagine he you know he's got this like
collection of ideas and he's hunting for
people and then he finds the person that
matches the idea then that launches and
that's what I'm seeing so that was
was really interesting there's also a
bunch of tax things that I kind of
that I knew in theory and they were like
you have to set this up now
so are there any examples of tax things
that uh that you took away as like holy
I can't believe I didn't do this
yeah
uh so qsbs
um the qualified small business
um basically what that means is you get
if you sell a company specifically a C
Corp you've held for at least five years
uh you get 10 million dollars in gains
tax-free at the federal level uh which
that's pretty huge that's amazing now
convertkit is an LLC and has been uh all
the way along
there's another rule inside of qsbs that
if you convert from an LLC to a C Corp
you get 10 the 10 million dollars or 10
times your basis whichever is greater
and in this case
you know convertk converting the assets
would be valued at 20 30 40 50 million
dollars and so those tax implications
would be uh potentially in the hundreds
of millions instead of 10 million and so
a few of those guys were like here's who
to talk to here's the lawyers who have
done this before like this is a very
important thing now it means that if I
can do that conversion I have to then
hold the business for another five years
um before any of that is eligible but
that's fine I'm planning to work on this
business for at least another 10.
there's another takeaway I I I knew
about this conversion and I almost did
it two years ago but then I was thinking
on the timeline
um and
just realizing one thing that another
guy there rameen pointed out seems like
look had you like five years seems like
a long time but had you done this when
you first learned about it
you that was two years ago you'd already
be 40 of the way through the five years
yeah and so thinking about like oh like
time actually goes by really quickly the
other thing with this is you don't have
to sell the whole company
right so like the enduring Ventures guys
they have this setup dialed in and they
have no plans to sell their whole
company but they want their investors
and their team and themselves to be able
to sell like in a secondary sale to be
able to sell like maybe 100 Grand or 500
Grand or a million dollars worth of
stock uh and to do it tax-free at the
federal level and that's
that's absolutely amazing and that's
something like we have that secondary
system set up for convertkit so I
realize like okay if I
converted all of this then it'd be huge
for my employees
yeah that makes a ton of sense and I
guess part of this is also uh there's
direct actionable things that you
probably pick up like the qsbs but also
uh it's just realizing hey this is
important I should pay attention right
somewhere to the ebitda thing like you
already kind of know it you kind of
think about your business uh with it to
some degree but uh when you're around
people who like that's their most
important thing I think it kind of
calibrates you on like oh maybe I should
put more importance on this doesn't mean
it has to become my most important thing
but it shouldn't be my least important
thing and it's their most important
thing like maybe I just need to move it
up a little bit uh in my priority list
and so uh it's funny when you have
friends that are operating cash flowing
businesses that operate tech companies
that operate Venture Capital firms
private Equity firms you know all these
different things they each put their
most important thing is different and so
in some way if you have all those
different friends then you can almost
you know find this equilibrium of like
all right I want to have you know fast
Revenue growth but doesn't need to be
the fastest I also want to have a
profitable business but it doesn't have
to have the highest profitability margin
and you got to put it together and you
end up with like a pretty good business
right you're like really good at a lot
of different things rather than have to
be the best at one thing and everything
else is like okay and I think that might
be uh might be an actual advantage in
the in the market especially in the
business you guys are in
yeah I think so and because
people want to go to one extreme or the
other and like everything happens in the
middle you know it's all like the world
is a whole lot of Shades of Gray and so
yeah it's just interesting seeing what
someone else prioritizes and you're
right because like there wasn't anything
that I learned
that was totally brand new like had
never heard it before but it was exactly
what you're saying of like oh you put
way more weight on this than I did or
like I know about qsbs I've known about
it for a long time and I've known about
this conversion but then realized like
having someone sit down and go okay
here's the numbers that
um actually matters
oh two other quick things that stood out
to me
all these guys are ridiculously good at
math in their heads I don't know if it's
because they have like Nick's background
in real estate or Styles background or
private Equity or romaine's background
and um uh like as a McKinsey consultant
and all that but I was just blown away
like talking about something they'd be
like
oh this return is that and just general
ahead and Romina would be like well Nick
it'd probably be six percent instead of
five and Nick would be like oh and you
just throw out all like the updated
number so I was like okay I don't know
they know Financial models and all that
really really well
and I think a lot of Founders are
probably like I'll hire someone for all
that
and you totally can but it made me think
like okay I need to level up my finance
game
and then the last one is agencies are a
great business I think coming from the
software world I'm like no SAS is where
it's at and I still think SAS is a
better business model
um but just like the number of agency
businesses that either they run in that
group or uh know about and know the
details of that are cash flow machines I
was like oh okay that was a bit of a
frame breaking thing for me I had
thought that you know maybe you make an
agency there's two million a year in
Revenue
500 000 a year in cash flow or something
like that like that's a really solid
business
but they were talking about these
companies they're like no no here's an
agency and they're just pulling up
examples from uh like the general
business Community we're like here's an
agency doing 20 million a year in cash
flow here's a an agency doing even more
than that
um and so it's fascinating watching
people use agencies to like power their
business Empires and their hotels and
all that yeah it um when a business
works I mean you can make money in a lot
of different things one of my favorite
things to do I don't think I've actually
ever said this publicly but uh uh one is
to go on Zillow and I go around the
country and I look at like different uh
properties and see our values going up
or down it's like you can get the like
economic data or whatever and it tells
you you know home prices but if you go
on Zillow like you very quickly can
filter and so you can see like you know
the super luxury home the like starter
home and you kind of filter around you
go on the map and you can like get a
very good sense of like our home price
is going up or down and like in the
Nuance of it but the second thing I like
to do after that is I like to go around
the country in some of the major cities
and go on like a buy Biz now or any of
these sites and basically look at what
are the businesses that are for sale
that are like the local businesses so
they're not usually software-based
businesses there's tons of like
restaurants and and that type of stuff
but also you'll get like uh Industrials
or there's always like a ton of lawn
care companies and those types of things
but you'll also see like uh the other
day I was on one in a city in Florida
and it was like a storm window
manufacturing and installation or there
was one that was a meat distribution and
processing right and you look at these
things and you're like dude this window
company literally makes 12 million
dollars a year in top line revenue and
books about 5 million in terms of free
cash flow like what is going on and it's
easy like there's hurricanes there's a
lot of rain and their pitch is like
Safety and Security both from crime or
from the weather like yeah they're gonna
to print money and so you look at that
you're like you know how much harder is
that business to run than a software
company depending on who you ask like
the person who knows that business is
like this is like I can do this in my
sleep the software entrepreneur is like
dude you have physical products like you
have to like install things right and
then vice versa yeah exactly so hard
yeah and so you look at these and and
what it gives you a good sense of is
like we spend so much time on the
internet so much time looking at
software that it's a great reminder that
like you can literally make money doing
anything and so when you see that it one
it's inspiring but two is it really
starts to make you calculate not just
how much money can you make in a
business how much time and effort does
it take to generate that money and I
think your idea about an agency is like
a perfect thing right where many
agencies are actually easier to run than
software companies because it's a proven
model like there's not uh kind of Market
risk there's execution risk but like
it's a well-known business model you
know where to find the customers you
know they're going to spend money on
this and it's just like can you win the
business versus someone down the street
a lot of software is like Hey we're
trying to build this thing that solves a
problem that you've never had a piece of
software to solve before and so when you
do that type of stuff it's much harder
because you're taking execution risk but
you're also taking Market risk and so in
some ways it's like yes you can make
more money but you also take more risk
hence the risk reward and so are you
better off just saying look let me go
and build businesses where I know
there's just execution risk again comes
down to the person but but I think it
just introduces this New Perspective a
lot of people don't think about the tech
industry as much
yeah just when you're talking about
execution risk and these in-person
businesses I've got a friend that
started a plumbing company here in Boise
where I live
he was not a plumber his previous
company was in tech and he's like look I
want to do something
tangible in the real world so he buys
this small plumbing company and he
doubles or doubles Revenue in six months
and doubles it again in another year so
18 months is uh basically Forex Revenue
and I asked him like what did you do
like how did you transform this is it
because the the Boise Market's growing
like crazy like what's happening he's
like yeah it's a good question I did two
things
I followed up with every lead that came
in and I showed up and did the job that
we were hired to do
uh and then he was like and then I like
asked for a referral you know so it's
like maybe three maybe he counted as
three full things and it was just such
an interesting thing of like wait you're
because everyone wants to know like
what's your uh um unfair Advantage you
know like what what's all that he's like
well I have a basic lead system and I
you know when someone calls up we answer
the phone
uh and then like show up to do an
estimate and all of that and then we do
good work and just realizing like oh
in some of these markets the bar is so
low uh and he's like yeah now it's a
great business and it's doing a couple
million a year in revenue and he's like
I'm gonna scale and now I'm just limited
to by how fast can I hire good plumbers
and that was fascinating to me so I've
talked on uh
um
on the podcast before about this but I
have a friend he's kind of a friend of a
friend who uh he had a whole thesis that
electricians were going to become way
more valuable in the future than they
are today because people weren't going
to trade schools and so like no one's
going to automate away the electrician
right anytime soon and so he basically
started to buy up kind of your local
electrician business sort of combine
them together he built a brand he did
the whole thing and so he essentially in
in one area of Canada and in Southern
California has these really large
Footprints of electricians and so what
he's seeing is like one the infusion of
new uh electricians is actually not
Rising so therefore you have a supply
demand imbalance which gives you pricing
power then if you have a large footprint
you have price setting ability and on
top of that you have new homes plus you
have kind of uh being able to fix
existing homes
it applies to residential and Commercial
right and so he has like this whole
thesis I remember thinking like damn I
don't like that's not me right like I'm
not that type of person who wants to go
do that and and frankly I would probably
get bored with it whatever but he loves
this and he is absolutely crushing it
and so if you think about uh from like a
talent Dynamic standpoint are there
certain Tailwinds in Industries like
Plumbing is probably another one how
many new you know kind of younger people
are going into either apprenticeship
mode or some sort of trade school to
learn Plumbing my guess is that actually
it's down significantly right in terms
of what it was five or ten years ago and
so same Dynamic happens and so when you
kind of go through uh these different
you know uh kind of as you said
in-person businesses
um just the supply demand you know
imbalance is attractive and then just
like do what you say you're gonna do and
so I have friends here in Miami who
they're like if I could just get someone
to come cut my grass
on the day they said they're gonna cut
it would be golden and so like the
running joke for people from New York
who like move here is like oh Miami time
right like you know somebody will say
that they're gonna come do something uh
whether it's work related whether it is
personal whatever they're like I'll be
there Tuesday at 8am and they show up
like Wednesday afternoon
and you're like hey man like we're not
even the same 24-hour period you know I
got caught up yesterday doing this or
whatever and like you're like okay cool
I get it but like just tell me that you
can't come Tuesday come Wednesday and so
to your point like literally just show
up on time do the job you said you're
gonna do follow up like these are basic
basic things and so for a tech
entrepreneur going to compete in these
other markets they're at such an
advantage that like again maybe it's
just easier to do that
yeah I there's this landscaper that I
started to use and he's done a few jobs
for me just around our property
and he sent me an estimate and he used
this tool called jobber
um where you can like view the estimates
pay a deposit online that's fantastic to
like text you uh and I love that and
then you sent me a loom video
of him like walking through the like
here's what the the plan answering
questions in the estimate
you know now like it stood out so much
to me
and I was like this is amazing like this
is the first time I've ever gotten a
loom video from a contractor you know
and just the fact that I could put a one
and a half speed right there and and
watch it I told him like uh I love this
and he was like yeah you're actually
like the fourth person this week who's
commented on the fact that I send Loom
videos and how easy it is to to
understand and all that because everyone
else is like mailing invoices and
estimates and all that so it's just
interesting the space that you decide to
compete in because like do you want to
go compete against the best of the best
you know in Silicon Valley and Tech or
do you want to
like go compete in a market that
like just leveling up these systems
implementing a CRM and saying like oh we
track all our leads and these deals
didn't close and so we're actually going
to follow up and see you know does Susie
actually want to do the kitchen remodel
that she reached out to us about six
months ago yes great 100
000 of Contracting work so so what I
what I think would be fun we didn't plan
this so uh hopefully I'm not putting you
on the spot here but um maybe we can
just like throw out ideas that like you
or I aren't gonna go do but like would
be really interesting things I'll go
first to give you a second to uh to
think but um Nick actually uh started
the cost segregation business and one of
the things people don't realize that
they do there is rather than have
someone physically come out to the
location they basically get the
homeowner or the the building owner on
FaceTime and they FaceTime and they're
able to do it right so you're using
technology uh for kind of a more
Antiquated model and so if you just use
that mechanism like where else could you
basically use video conferencing right
or FaceTime or whatever to replicate
having someone physically drive out to a
location and you see this with like
telemedicine right they're trying to
figure out how to do that but there's
probably a bunch of other Industries
where literally now I don't have to show
up I can just have the personally the
rent and hold up their phone and do ABC
whatever and it feels like there's a ton
of business that'll be there
um any ideas like that that you've seen
that you think are interesting or people
could uh could take away
yeah another one on that one that Nick's
doing really well is he's hiring a lot
of uh team members in Latin America for
that and so there's some really great
cost benefits
um and then what I love is as he talks
about that he also has a recruiting firm
to help you go hire you know so he's got
that that um full circle as you were
talking about the electricians
and the like the pricing power
um
and just the market dynamics
one of the things that's coming up is
the scarcity of electricians right
that's going to be driving the market
down the road
and so a similar idea
you know with the consulate business
you're saying okay where can we take
virtual tours you know basically or this
off-site camera idea and change the
business
one thing I hear in the electrician
business is the electrician themselves
is the bottleneck like you think from a
theory of constraints perspective
we can only scale this business so much
that we can as we can get clients and we
can get electricians and I think it's
going to be easier to get clients and
electricians especially if the trade
schools are not turning out as many
and so what I think about is okay how do
you be the best employer how do you be
the one where people are like hell yes I
want to work as an electrician here
because they take really good care of me
um you know the benefits are fantastic
like go interview
20 electricians and find out what sucks
about their job and what are the things
that may not be monetary because say you
want to you want to pay competitively
um but what could you offer that is
going to get them to say like oh this is
a great place to work and tell their
other friends like hey man I'm sorry
that your boss sucks but I'm loving
working over here especially in any
Market where they're actually the
constraint
and so if you're saying hey I'm going to
be the best employer for electricians
then I'm going to always be able to
recruit more
I don't have to buy my competitor's
business I can just
slowly siphon away all of their talent
and then I can you know maybe pick up
their business or their territory for
pennies on the dollar because they
actually can't uh fulfill customer needs
and so if you're looking through you
know in this whole shift as the talent
World changes with AI and everything
else
um
what businesses have employees where
where the employee is key it cannot
function without it you can't Outsource
it you can't anything like that
and then what would have to be true for
you to be the absolute best employer in
that market where people are saying
oh I'd kill the work for Palms company
in this in this area because then
you've zeroed in on the biggest
constraint and then you've made it so
you're the best person to work there so
I think that any of these Services
businesses landscapers plumbers uh
electricians all of those could do it
really well
to an extent you can do it in software
but it's not as
the constraints not as strong because
you don't have you're not geographically
Limited
um I don't do any other companies come
to mind that
like the people really really matter and
you could win purely on Talent so I
don't even know if it's just uh like
Talent alone but I think what you're
talking about is in a given City uh
there's only so many people who are
world class right or city class at doing
X and so if you go back to you know uh
this the um kind of hurricane uh proof
windows right right how many window
installers are actually the best in this
specific City uh where I was looking
right and I don't know maybe there's
five or ten of them if you go get the
five or ten best window installers in
that City on your team then like you win
right because literally everyone's like
oh they have the best window installers
right and so uh in some way it's not
even like the window installer is uh
absolutely vital we couldn't teach
anyone else how to do this they'd have
to go to trade school or whatever like
an electrician has a certain skill set
that takes much longer to to kind of
learn uh I'm sure window installing is
difficult as well but it seems like that
might be simpler to learn it's not a
licensed skill in the same way correct
but like damn you could create a mini
Monopoly in your city and if you just
dominate the talent through the same
mechanism it isn't a supply Demand on
like a national scale it's just Supply
Demand on this you know local city level
like all of the window uh business and
revenue comes to you right right and so
if you think about that that becomes
interesting the other thing is uh I
think a lot about like on time
and so you know I was joking earlier
about friends who would be like oh like
the guy who's supposed to cut my grass
like he comes like a day late or
whatever but actually if you think about
a lot of businesses their vendors one of
the biggest problems they have is
they're not on time and so you know
Trucking may be like a really simple one
where uh is the truck driver
quote-unquote essential uh no you can
get somebody else right and a lot of
people don't know this but like Walmart
I think the starting salary for a truck
driver now is like over 100 Grand right
so if you basically get the license and
you start driving at Walmart you make
100 Grand Flex on Instagram and tell
everyone you got you know you make six
figures right
um but what becomes fascinating about it
is if you just have a business where
your people are trained to a certain
standard that is a differentiator so
again you can find truck drivers
everywhere but maybe it's not the truck
driver who is the quote-unquote
differentiating factor like having an
inverse not it's Noah truck driver that
meets you know two or three main things
hey they're commutative uh they're on
time and you know uh I don't know they
drive really safe for I'm making it up
but it feels like that ends up being
something that the business owner can
control outside of just like hey I got
all of the electricians right and so
um that that comes to mind but the other
one that I think about a lot is uh chefs
so what I'm shocked by that no one has
really done yet is local entrepreneurs
saying I don't want to do virtual
kitchens across the country or anything
like that instead what I'm going to do
is I'm going to take the five best chefs
in a certain city and we're going to do
the virtual kitchen thing but we not
only want to deliver uh via the Ubers
and the doordashes and those platforms
we also are going to make stuff Frozen
that we can ship or we're going to make
things that aren't perishable that we
can ship right because if you really
think about that kitchen right now most
of the virtual kitchens they are for
local delivery so your addressable
Market fits within kind of a a radius
but if all of a sudden you're able to
create things out of that same kitchen
that can be shipped somewhere
game on right and so like you get into
this very interesting world where like
you're almost increasing the like
Revenue per square foot
by opening up the addressable market and
then this is where things like uh
content distribution marketing paid ads
Etc the better you are at that stuff now
you're just playing e-commerce
right and so you you kind of marry these
two
you're also I'm just thinking about the
way that kitchen operates
if you're in a specific Geographic
Market you have
um spikes in demand right lunchtime
dinner time
3 P.M on a Tuesday we're not really very
busy there's not a lot happening you
know and so I've got a staff you know
I've got I'm Staffing up for three or
four hours for lunch and then tapering
off and Staffing up for dinner and so
what you're talking about is using some
of this
uh the slack time you know in our in our
kitchen and saying hey during that time
we're going to be producing uh maybe
meals that are frozen or
um right or things for another Market
where that that doesn't have the same
capacity limitations I think also in
these local businesses if you think
about okay what are we going to do
through the winter if we're a
landscaping business and if you have a
great answer for that you're like I keep
my employees employed all through the
winter with something more like
something better than snow removal than
like
that that's going to be a huge thing
um or you could just live in Miami where
winter's not a thing that would work too
um but I think a ton about what level do
you want to compete
do you want to compete at the top right
so two electrician companies going
head-to-head for the market who can
drive the most leads who has the best
brand who has the best reputation in the
industry uh all of that you can and
should compete at that level
or like on the other end do you want to
compete like deep in the business for
talent and it's like look if I if I win
all of your talent then you can't
compete with me at the top level I think
another thing like for convertkit you
know building
email marketing software and all this
competing at the top is like do we have
better features than MailChimp do we
um you know in this particular thing
someone's like hey do you have a or
versus B right and we're we're competing
feature by feature or on the Brand level
and we absolutely compete there
but where we're looking to compete now
is like what do creators care about
creators care about getting paid and so
now we're taking the angle of like how
can we just make sure that we're growing
your audience faster than any other
platform and paying you more money
so like one thing that we launched is
this uh sponsor Network and that's
what's selling all the advertising in
sawhill's newsletter
and it's it's effectively a small agency
inside of convertkit saying hey we will
do all the advertising and sponsorships
for you you know we'll just take 20
percent
and so now when someone's like wait
I don't pay convertkit convertkit pays
me like all of a sudden it moves from at
the top level like what features do you
have or all that to like look I'm never
moving away because I get paid to be
here you know Style's making 25 000 a
month off the sponsorships that he
doesn't have to sell and so
after spending like 10 years competing
head to head on the feature set and
brand and all of that then we're now
shifting and saying okay how can we
compete on what you care about most
which is getting creators paid
um and so that like
that's the way that I like to shift the
thinking is what actually do people care
about most and how can I go straight
there instead of competing in the
traditional sense
when you start thinking about uh kind of
the business that you're building how do
you determine whether to create
something like that internally versus
Outsource it versus uh go buy a business
that you're then gonna kind of bring
inside like talk a little bit about the
decision making so you're like hey we
want to help people make more money we
know that selling ads is a way to do
that how do we enter into helping what's
that process like
yeah so
my first thing is to like get crazy
excited about it and distract my team
and and all of that and I actually got a
good little like mini Nick Huber lecture
about the this over the weekend
um because he was like look you're
coming in and you're going to your exec
team you're like here's this new idea
and it's so exciting and they're like
what are you doing we already have goals
we already have exactly what we're
working towards like don't distract
don't mess this up
and Nick was saying like look they're
right
you know convertkits course inscription
revenue does 34 million a year like
that's the Golden Goose don't don't
screw that up keep everybody focused
and and you should not be you know
distracting your team with these new
ideas
and what's funny is that he was like
you're also right
that this is a great idea and it 100
should be pursued
and like so what you need
what's that both are true
yeah both are true you need to hire a
team either inside of convertkit
specifically to pursue this that's what
we did with this sponsor Network idea
where we built out a team internally
that they have their own goals they're
not distracting the rest of the team or
priorities
um you know or you need to spin it up
separately right run it as an
independent company and
all right so two examples on this with a
sponsor Network it's basically an agency
um you know a software backed agency
running inside of convertkit making that
happen
and that was just really Scrappy to get
going
um I think a month ago we just passed a
million dollars in sponsorship sold
across that and we actually still
haven't written any major code it's all
like no code systems running all that
because it's like let's prove out the
model before we do something really
expensive like put five Engineers for
six months on it
um because that like engineering time is
one of the biggest constraints in our
business
and so that's how we spin that up
um another example is uh sahil Bloom and
I are actually starting an agency that
does newsletter growth because for a
long time I've thought about
um
that convertkit should have a Services
arm because you get these creators who
are like you know I want to do this and
that like can you do it all for me it's
like well we're a software company like
we we you know we sell software we don't
do services
and I thought that you know Converse
should have a Services armed that could
do that for people but like that's a
whole thing to build up how does it fit
in the model and all that it's like oh
you know on Nick's advice you spin it up
as a separate company and then we have
it built in where if we ever want to
fold that in to convertkit and that
makes sense we can do it but like this
other side is not a distraction to the
team and so we can run these smaller
tests and then uh scale them how much of
how much of it is uh you're able to do
this because uh you've built a business
that you all own uh and you kind of
don't need approvals
yeah I think that's I think that's a big
thing I bet if I had you know if I own
30 of the business because I had several
co-founders and we'd raised you know 50
million in venture capital
I I don't think these things would work
but because at this point you know I own
85 percent of the business and have
taken no outside Capital then yeah I can
be like hey I'm gonna try this thing and
then if it works then I'm gonna
um
like scale it up and and put like true
systems behind it
talk a little bit about uh convertkit
today how big is it uh kind of how do
you think about the business
yeah so it's got a couple components to
it um we're 70 people uh we 34 million a
year in Revenue subscription based
um
the target's creators so you know
someone building a newsletter uh all
that
anyone like maybe just launched a
newsletter or podcast and I'm paying
nine dollars a month for you know a few
hundred subscribers or on the free plan
um all the way up to most of the biggest
newsletters in the web so like James
Clare Tim Ferriss
um Susan Kane a lot of the authors Ryan
holiday I'll run the newsletters and
convertkit and then
oh we've got a bunch in the
entertainment space which is fun you
know Tim McGraw uh Arnold Schwarzenegger
it's a great daily newsletter on
convertkit
um which is fun to read my favorite
thing is when he's on like Jimmy Kimmel
or something and he's talking about like
go sign up for my newsletter
um
I wish you'd say there was a conversion
we'll get that in later
um other things in the business I guess
things that I'm really thinking about a
lot right now are how to get to 100 net
dollar retention
and so that's uh for anyone who doesn't
know you'd also phrase that as net
negative Revenue turn but basically your
expansion revenue from existing
customers growing is bigger than you
know any turn from cancellations
and so that's been a big Focus to the
last year of like how do you make a much
stickier product how do you make a
product that helps people grow faster so
we've currently gotten it all the way to
99 net dollar retention which in like
the small business Market is pretty good
but I'm like oh you know the next three
months
one more
yeah so close
um but yeah now it's it's thinking about
what other things can we tack on I was
at converted Commerce which is a
like how you sell digital products So
Paid newsletters
um ebooks coaching all of that
um and that's still pretty small but
processing uh like about a million
dollars a month in payments on behalf of
creators
um
and then there's like sponsorship of an
advertising Network
um and so basically like how can we make
creators more money is
uh how that works and then because we we
end up making a small percentage of all
of it
when you think about the journey that
you've had doing this
um would you go back and raise Venture
funding or bootstrapped
in hindsight what's the right way to go
yeah bootstrap does the right thing for
me I'm not one of those people that's
like bootstrap ride or die or Venture
Capital you know
um there's plenty of people who want to
have flame Wars on the internet about
which one's better and
I don't care that much
but like my style of operating and I
think for this business bootstrapped is
is absolutely right
because he like too many companies
when money's easy to come by too many
companies can spend too much time
Building without like really validated
with customers and I had to get customer
funding
you know from the beginning and so
that's kept us really really close to
customers
and then I think there's other things of
like being able to
take distributions and
make money along the way and not just
worry about the exit you know like a lot
of Founders are basically broke for a
very long time and then they sell and
they're insanely wealthy and
um you know building a bootstrap company
you can have like this much more
sensible net worth Arc and so that's
something of like you know I can take
healthy salary and distributions from
convertkit
and build a lot of Enterprise Value so I
get in that it lets you play that cash
flow versus Enterprise Value and you
don't have to go all in on one or the
other you'll be like look I can do both
yeah I think it's uh I think it's super
smart uh the last thing I want to uh
talk about before uh lets you go is
um you live in San Francisco you don't
live in New York you live in Miami or
Austin uh La uh Singapore Dubai you know
name them I don't know maybe the top 25
most popular places that uh Tech
entrepreneurs like to brag about you're
in none of them talk a little bit about
uh kind of how you thought about where
to live build the business remote versus
person Etc
all right yeah so I live in Boise Idaho
on a nine Acre Farm that that uh we live
on and raise our three boys here
there's this idea that someone said I
think it was a guy named Sean Blanc who
I first heard it from and said if you
work with your mind you should rest with
your hands
this idea of like we spend all this time
in front of the computer all day
and you know grinding it out making our
businesses better
and like when you're not doing that you
should find something tangible I like
woodworking I like building things I
like gardening farming you know and a
lot of my best ideas come when I'm doing
something with my hands that like just
lets my brain wander
um so uh Boise is a really good place
for that also another thing how often do
people like to get the like pomp I'm in
I'm in Miami let's grab coffee 20 times
a day yeah people know that uh that's
not my gig so uh it's more so they stop
asking yeah no one asked me that in
Boise yeah I'm gonna go do lunch with
somebody uh today and it'll be like one
a month I get to be like heads down on
my company
um because
yeah it's not not that whole thing and
so I think
it's been really good to live outside of
those markets and then once a month or
every couple months be like hey I'm
gonna go to San Francisco and line up a
ton of meetings or New York and and just
like batch that and say basically I go
from
building mode to networking mode and
move between that and say like hey I'm
I'm in building mode 95 of the time and
then I'm going to switch into networking
mode when I'm going to speak in this
conference in New York and then I'm
going to line up a bunch of meetings
around it
um
and so that that's worked really well
for me and I think you're just going to
see a lot more of it as companies stay
remote after covid and and uh all that
but like
there's a ton of benefits to being in
the in big cities and being around other
Founders and I would just like be really
clear for yourself are those benefits
that like are just social or ego or like
or are you really taking the most
advantage of that like is that serving
you to go to the 12th founder dinner of
the month
um or do you actually just need to sit
down and build your company
yeah I um uh I tell a lot of young
people can you hit the 30 minute dinner
and they always like what do you mean so
uh people who live here in mind we're
gonna laugh they hear this
I only go for 30 minutes there's people
I know very well highly respect them uh
they do dinner a lot they're you know
always inviting me uh I'm very uh
thankful that they invite me I got
things to do and so what I do is I just
show up for 30 minutes
and I say hey look I'm not here to eat
and whatever I just want to say hi to
everyone you know gotta go bye and uh
the big hack was uh when we had our
daughter right oh I got I got a little
one at home oh I love it I gotta get her
to bed yeah it's so great to see you all
and maybe there's two people that you
meet that you really wanted to meet and
so you can do that and then if you hit
it off you're like hey like let me give
you a call when uh I'm out pushing her
in a stroller and she falls asleep and
like I'll give you a call next week you
know and you can actually do that that's
great just smash it all into 30 minutes
and then now though uh I gotta be
careful because uh if I go to one of
these dinners they don't even like save
me a place to like eat so oh my God damn
I guess I really gotta go in 30 minutes
like I was actually hungry and they're
like oh for once you were gonna stay
yeah yeah exactly
um all right where can we send people to
find you on the internet find out more
about convertkit
yeah uh good stuff so I write a
newsletter at Nathan berry.com uh
berries b-a-r-ry
and then if you're building an audience
on the internet
um and you want to use convert it just
convertkit.com we'll happily migrate
anyone over for free and uh yeah just
follow our buildings
um I do some interviews on a show just
the Nathan Berry show if you search on
uh anywhere podcasts are that's where
I'm having conversations with people I
find interesting and
that's all I got
dude I enjoyed talking every time we
talk uh you've built an amazing company
and uh I love the way you guys are
thinking about everything so thank you
so much for doing this we'll definitely
do it again in the future
sounds good thanks for having me